[Música]
cuál de estas dos personas
es más confiable
es más espiritual
una de estas dos personas robó en el
supermercado
quiero
un estudio de la universidad de
questions realizado más de 45 mil
personas demostró
que tardamos menos de un segundo en
aceptar o rechazar a una persona en
nuestro primer encuentro
en menos de un segundo nuestra mente ya
sabe si esa persona nos cae bien o no si
creemos que se acerque o se aleje que
hable o que calle
la decisión
te quiero no te quiero confío en ti no
confío en ti me atraes no me atraes está
fundamentada por una enorme cantidad de
argumentos que hemos ido acumulando a lo
largo de toda nuestra vida
vivencias relatos conversaciones
mitos leyendas verdades y mentiras
estos días aquí en la argentina hay una
frase que me gustó mucho y quisiera
compartir con ustedes
oí que alguien decía
el que se quema con leche
de una vaca y ahora
y yo pensaba por qué
la vaquita inocente comiendo la pasto
y nosotros a su lado llorando
es que el modo en el que cada uno de
nosotros interpreta la realidad
está condicionado por nuestra
predisposición mental
que a su vez está condicionada por todas
las experiencias del pasado
hace un tiempo en el himalaya un monje
me dijo
yo
tú has ido alguna vez a las islas de
hawai
no le dije yo
pero para ti existen
sí claro
y como sabes que existen si nunca las
has visto
bueno pues porque las he visto en vídeos
documentales y demás imágenes
de eso quería hablar me dijo el monje
gran parte de lo que creemos conocer
no lo hemos conocido en primera persona
nos lo han contado
encendemos el mundo a partir de imágenes
relatos notas de prensa películas
y sobre todo los medios masivos de
comunicación
entonces
si nuestro modo de entender el mundo y
de evitarlo
depende de nuestras fuentes de
información
más vale que sean confiables
sin embargo les traigo malas noticias
un estudio de la universidad montes
sostiene que tres de cada cuatro
artículos en la prensa contiene serias
inconsistencias
otro artículo afirma que siete de cada
diez periodistas en lugar de investigar
prefieren ver netflix
hay otro estudio que sostiene que un
estudio afirma que los estudios podrían
no ser del todo confiables
y finalmente
hay un estudio de la universidad de
world fund
que sostiene
que ningún dato de los que fueron
ofrecidos en esta charla
son ciertos
que quien les habla no tiene 80 años
sino 33
que no nació en estados unidos de
norteamérica sino en argentina
que no es un académico
sino un actor
y el estudio concluye diciendo que
vivimos demasiado convencidos y
convencidas de que nuestro modo de ver
el mundo es la posta
[Aplausos]